[Musique]
aussitôt arrivé dans notre département
le ministre d outre-mer sébastien
lecornu s'est rendu hommage au plus près
des incendies après avoir rencontré les
soldats du feu il a annoncé l'arrivée de
renforts humains et matériels ont
embarqué 80 sapeurs-pompiers ont
renforts nationaux souvent des
militaires mais pas qu'eux qui ont
embarqué du sud de la france de
marseille delà de la base d'istres qui
vont rejoindre ici l'île de la réunion
que sous sol
consommez 35 tonnes c'est à dire la
moitié du stock de retardant que la
réunion peut avoir donc on va
reconstituer très vite en urgence 36
tonnes qui vont arriver dans les heures
qui viennent
si le feu semble aujourd'hui fixé le
bilan se chiffre à 175 hectares de forêt
brûlés une perte de la végétation
indigène sur ce site naturel
le département participe activement en
lien avec l'eau à nef et le parc
national à la protection la préservation
de ces zones forestières et aujourd'hui
donc on va commencer à travailler sur
balles à la reprise on va dire la
régénération de ces espaces forestiers
les renforts vont permettre aux pompiers
de maîtriser les points chauds détecter
et empêcher un nouveau départ de feu la
forêt du maïdo classé au patrimoine
naturel de l'unesco est encore sous
haute surveillance
[Musique]